don't wake up to the World Cup on an
empty stomach I prepared a delicious
World Cup brunch menu just for you this
is the perfect brunch dish I've Austin
rancheros
now the secret behind this is in the
heat first of all start sweating off
your peppers and your onions now red
peppers green peppers now the secret
behind this dish she's going to play
with that score now this wouldn't be a
Mexican dish without that incredible
garlic I'm a big lover of garlic so load
up that crusher crush that garlic in you
see those onions and those peppers
coming to light roast off the garlic
really important when you start
caramelized onions peppers garlic always
keep nice and flat in the pan now we hit
that with some beautiful fresh cumin
generous on the cumin that gives it that
really nice still dark rich Mexican
flair from their secret sauce this is a
smoked to pull a puree that's gonna give
a bit of body and a bit of heat to the
sauce get that into the bottom of the
pan and get that roasting now look
what's happening to the sauce
beautiful get this sauce right and it's
90 percent of the battle from there you
take this beautiful spicy chorizo
sausage we're gonna crumble that in that
starts to give the sauce and a little
bit of body and puts that nice sort of
rich texture to the sweetness of those
peppers finally I can tomatoes that's
gonna give it that beautiful richness
and make it a lot lighter this
especially for breakfast bring that up
to the boil and literary
that out for three and a half to four
minutes you can see the sources reduce
down it smells incredible now take it
off the heat and I like this sauce to be
sort of smooth and blitz so stick mix
you can put it in the blender but stick
mix just makes it sort of refined chunky
and incredibly delicious look at that
that's the base of our breakfast
now beans and eggs first off the beans
now lightly all the pan get it nice and
hot I want a bit of color on these beans
so beans go in salt pepper nicely
seasoned a little bit of lime sprinkle
over lime and then literally you squeeze
the fresh lime over the beans now that
lift sees the beans up and giving them a
little bit of sort of texture seasoning
beautiful now eggs this breakfast
wouldn't be complete without that
richness of an amazing beautiful fried
egg literally tap the egg and crack back
into the pan again tap and crack a nice
fry eggs I like to get the edges crispy
and put a little bit of butter over the
size that helps the blister the egg
white but more importantly the flavor
that butter delicious salt and pepper
gently over those yolks lightly seasoned
useful tilt the pan
based those eggs without butter and
that's the secret behind cooking a
beautiful egg and just leave those eggs
to sit in that hot pan in England
without toast in America whatever bagel
but in Mexico they have the tortilla now
the seat behind these tortillas is
lightly grilling them just gently
sprinkle a touch of olive oil on top of
the tortilla and then too straight onto
the grill because that just lifts it to
another level one is our base the other
one just take a little spoon of beans
and turn it into something magical and
that literally just sits on the side and
that's got you little surprise in there
now putting this beautiful breakfast
together start off with our sauce
straight on to that but here be generous
from the start scattering my beans in a
relaxed manner casual relaxed but look
at the flavors we're building and now my
beautiful fried eggs once it's on there
and the other one just slightly overlaps
a few more beans scattered around and
then touch more sauce over the beans
over the side of the egg we start to
bring it together ring and little
avocado just a squeeze of lime juice in
there that stops it from oxidizing take
your spoon and just starts to scatter
them on top beautiful finally
- your cheese and just lightly sprinkle
that on top not too heavy this wouldn't
have that Mexican Flair without a touch
of cilantro that come on seriously who
would not get our bet for that delicious
brunch it's all part of my official
World Cup brunch menu now the recipes
are online download right now and make
your FIFA World Cup viewing party on Fox
extra special